if there's one thing to remember it's
this fire fades and it's inevitable and
natural for the world to return to dark
the future is dark but it was not always
this way let's go back to where there
was a flame the hero has made it to the
kiln where the first flame was found
variety faded and was kindled again the
hero descends to kill the God who
kindled that flame this God is a shell
now husk
he's lost his kingdom his knights his
wife children and Friends
but even with nothing left he sacrificed
himself to keep the dark at bay this is
the story of a man who fought against
the inevitable in the beginning there
were two planes of existence
there was the above and the below above
was grey with dragons who had existed
forever nothing changed nothing
progressed and nothing lived or died I
think of the below as dark although it
probably was nothing of the sort
how can darkness exist without light but
that was about to change because when
the flame came it created disparity now
there was light and dark and the light
illuminated the creatures who are hiding
these creatures emerged to inspect the
flame and thieves were the ones who had
become known as giants for within the
flame was great power and for giants
claimed this power they claimed it and
it shaped them NATO came to embody death
the witch of izalith represented life
Lord Gwyn stood for the light and the
pygmy kept his Dark Soul a secret Gwyn
decreed that the flame was more powerful
than the gray existence up above and the
Giants declared war on the Dragons to
claim the surface alas the Dragons were
immortal and many nights of Gwyn fell
but there was one dragon who betrayed
his own Seath the scaleless born without
the stone scales of immortality told the
dragon's weakness to Gwyn the stone
scales were the secret to their
immortality and the lightning was their
weakness
so Gwyn and his Knights fashioned bolts
of lightning to peel apart their stone
scales
nito unleashed disease on their exposed
flesh and the witch of izalith and her
followers used fire sorceries to burn
their homes the arch trees to ash and
the Dragons were no more and so the age
of fire was born and the Giants began
their own story but since this is a
story about light it is also a story
about dark for it is inevitable that one
day the flame will fade and only dark
will remain seethe was granted three
rewards he received a piece of Gwynn's
Lord soul a dukedom in Quinn's kingdom
and his own research facility to
discover immortality something he never
would have had with the dragons around
the age of fire had changed the shape of
the world
Gwyn's Kingdom grew during the age of
fire and the lands outside assumedly
looked to lordran as their capital city
an Orlando was built close to the Sun
and eventually smaller towns and cities
grew to surrounded the Giants became the
royalty and the gods and humanity spread
worshipping those more powerful than
them
Gwynne himself had a wife whose name is
not known and by her he had three
children his firstborn was the God of
War who formed the warriors of sunlight
however he lost the annales which were
historical records Gwyn decreed that his
son would share the same fate and old
record of the firstborn was stripped
from the land Gwyn second born Guinevere
was well loved with her own statues and
covenant the princess guard the third of
birth was Gwendolyn who was born frail
and deformed he was raised as a daughter
since he was proficient at moonlight
magic which is considered a female trait
his existence was hidden and his
covenant to the blade of the dark moons
on down sinners and protect the illusion
of power in Anor Londo for hundreds of
years the Lord's prospered but
everything ends locked away in his
archives seth is desperately searching
for the secret to immortality the six
side-channel was read for him and
searched the world for test subjects
these test subjects are locked away in
Crystal golems for transportation back
to the archives where they become the
subject of his experiments at the base
of the prison there are pisacas twisted
monsters created from captured maidens
if you listen carefully you can hear
them crime
at some point the knowledge in the
archives sends Seath mad it's impossible
to know whether he was insane before or
after his experiments on the maidens but
one way or another
Gwyn turns a blind eye to the happenings
in the archives perhaps it was this that
led to the rebellion against the gods in
the war against the Dragons Lord Gwyn
had a friend and camp atria named Havel
the rock who was the sworn enemy of
magic and seat the scales after the war
Quinn granted safe dukedom and a part of
his own soul perhaps Havel was bitter at
Quinn's preference for Seif since he
started to collect items capable of
killing the gods hidden in his basement
in Anor Londo there is an occult Club
items of the occult can kill the gods
and are rightly feared Havel was also a
bishop of the church who knew the
whereabouts of the dark Ember lastly the
effigy shield states that there was once
an ill-fated plot to destroy the God's
ill-fated because the attempt failed
among the royalty there are rumors of a
hero locked away in a stone cell by a
dear friend they say he was locked away
for his own good which led many to
believe that the man inside had gone
Hollow Havel helped Gwyn win his throne
but met with the fate of the undead and
was kept in a Cell so he could not harm
others that's what they would have you
believe but what if Gwyn learnt of
Havel's plan to kill the gods perhaps
Havel was not hollow when he was locked
away perhaps he was locked away for the
good of the room and left to hollow in
the middle of an area overrun by hollows
Gwyn would have locked his friend away
for the greater good but was it the
right thing to do this marks the peak of
the age of fire and the darkness is
looming soon Gwyn will need all the
friends he can get
you